si capisce che questo video è
sponsorizzato sonic
adesso si va beh questo non lo metto dai
facciamo che i miei capelli sono già
abbastanza sonici da soli è la tutti
ragazzi e benvenute questo video sono fa
vj e oggi sono su sony forces difficoltà
normale difficile ma secondo te metto
normale io questi capelli posso mettere
normale ciao come non solo perché quei
capelli e tu sei pelato in realtà non so
se mi consigli posso spoilerare che cosa
succede quindi salto i filmati onde
evitare che mi blocchino tutto che vado
avanti che media perfetto ci sia venne
però miss over cavalca quanto veloce
aiuto aiuto e parti che cosa cos'è fermi
aiuto quanto veloce e vabbè che allora
non mi aspettavo mai nella vita una cosa
del genere prendendo una capsula whisper
riempirà e l'indicatore turno che ti fa
sentire un topo ok quindi vabbè tipo io
quando andavo a scuola c'è premix per
saltare grazie l'avevo intuito né si
attacca nemici aiuto sono fortissimo e
seguì in attacco ricerca facendo un
salto prevedere il suo andare a su luxus
i premi va bene va bene ok molto
semplice perfetto ma do raga ma quanto
assurdo
guardate enorme green hill sembra sempre
più
giocare a questo gioco è come bere 26
energy drink e di fila questo tutorial
fino adesso abbiamo solo scherzato
grazie scusi eh va beh
yes dei più bei ragazzi per adesso me la
sto cavando da creare il tuo avatar
personale ha già adesso grandi lavata
personale cane lupo coniglio orso gatto
uccello porcospino anche uno c'è la sua
abilità uccello ma cos'è questa roba
cosa vera e vabbè sembrano i capelli dei
truzzi di dieci anni fa ragazzi
capigliatura e quella se mi metto gli
occhi di notte mica go addosso
guardandomi allo specchio ecco questo va
be che dormo colore degli occhi che non
posso cambiare perché sono un sì va bene
rosa laga mi accontento magnifico ho
creato un essere truzzo quei capelli
rosa niente male o scassato tutto scusa
non volevo sbagliato dai ragazzi mentre
sarti preseguire un attacco cablato
sull'unico ok ma è lo stesso di prima a
me fin qua ma vado al meno veloce come
puglia si mischiano che la metà basta ma
vado veloce parti parti parti 130h vacca
c'era uno scalino in teoria ragazzi io
non avevo giocato a tutti quanti giochi
di sonic fino adesso quindi
probabilmente sono uno scarsone del
normale che sia così però avendo giocato
ok inascoltate che mi stavo concentrando
aiuto aiuto succedono cose caldi fermi
tutti sto arrivato il campione del mondo
questo l'ha fatto in un minuto e 4
secondi
accetto la sfida raga devo farcela devo
farla in meno di un minuto e 4 secondi
si vabbé non solo ma il campione del
mondo però ai weiwei velocissimo subito
me ne frega niente di tutto quello che
devo fare un minuto cielo mentre vai
carica carica di bestia
ok la partenza non è male la partenza
non è male se non fosse sempre fermo
perfetto va così e così appoggiato remo
essere a metà a livello e per di tipo
che ha battuto il record però va bene fa
niente corri quanto tempo mamma mia
quanto lento e vabbè quanto scarso a
tutti ma tutti veloce veloce e non l'ho
mancato sono scarse
mamma mia quanto lento mia nonna è più
veloce veloce ok 38 secondi non ce la
farò mai
e finito se prendo se prendo le porte in
faccia anche io se prendo le porte in
faccia magari no che ho provato abbiamo
pure pure colpito la pena champagne un
punteggio veramente pietoso ma va bene
così 149 fa veramente schifo ma non
importa
tu continua a fare più belli d'abruzzo
che sei contento save faccio non ad un
buon alito neanche lei proprio niente io
io io parto che sono caduti o parto che
sono caduto nocerino ma moscerino a fiat
ea me che sono tipo un porcospino sei tu
quello che ha le ali dei lupi
no non l'ho colpito l'ho colpito va bene
è già qualcosa
potresti smetterla di evocare api che mi
dà fastidio
agi luton bene grazie non dovevi
ascoltarmi alla lettera ma meglio così
quanto boss mamma mia ok ancora ancora
ancora un cazzotto destro io ho perso di
nuovo contro uno come te
bello guarda qualcuno che la prossima
quando non sapete come insultare un
vostro nemico da teli del venditore di
hot dog che fa sempre il suo effetto
sì ma una un attimo una aiuto non capì
livelli parti un attimo quanto veloce
occhio
mammamia meno male croce riflessi pronti
a quest'ora se diciamo mettere in pausa
questo già è più facile mettere in pausa
un videogioco online che sonic perché
come in pausa non capisce più dove sei
tu lo stai facendo a cosa stai giocando
se ai partiti è una mamma mia quanto
casino
ovviamente io mi sposto esattamente
nella corsia dove mi stanno sparando mi
sembra giusto c'è veramente assurdo
bocchio qualsiasi cosa abbiate in testa
ai core sonic può farla solo sony
fantastico e gli agenti speciali possono
accompagnare solo vai così c'è un
paracadute o cosa no non c'è ma io cado
in piedi che è un piacere ma io sapevo
che i gatti cadevano in piedi senza
farsi male non i porcospini però va bene
però ragazzi prendo sempre aree cioè è
già qualcosa fiocco invece mi starà
benissimo anche così da nudo non so
niente male
grazie sony che se non fosse per te il
tutto bene
veramente messa ha fatto tu però per far
niente
corrono e vanno ai mille all'ora cioè
parte l'astronave parte non si vede più
la pasta la fai cuocere dieci minuti o
coach e istantaneamente quando l'afa non
so non capisco io preferisco utilizzare
il mio perché al doppio salto e col
doppio salto mi trovo benissimo
sicuramente la pasta cuoce subito
[Musica]
ce l'abbiamo fatta
e vabbè per adesso non è niente di
troppo difficile quindi apprezzata anche
in picchiata la loro aumentiamo la
difficoltà noi da loro cadono in piedi
che un piacere cioè fantastico vorrei
averlo io so se per poter invece di
uscire di casa dall'ascensore panda al
quinto piano
ho fatto una cosa che secondo me non
devo fare di quella fabbrica è un casino
non mi conviene usare la velocità qua
dentro perché come la uso cado giù cake
in un attimo quindi vado sparo e basta
ok come dall'inizio
vabbè dai la musica è il mio genere raga
non so se sarà capito aiuto ma basta
fonti sono non vorrei dire ma lo sto
giocando in difficoltà difficile quindi
non ho neanche messo quella normale
apprezzate il gesto apprezzate che mi
metto alla prova e apprezzate e non
apprezzate niente ogni volta che ho un
muro davanti mica go addosso per mi
ricordo che ci sono i cosiddetti saltano
in automatico ma parla per te zio perché
stai zitto che è meglio ce l'abbiamo
fatta
ok allora il cappellino credo che siamo
tutti d'accordo questo direi o queste le
ultime fashion da spiaggia classiche
però credo questo anzi non mettiamo
della spiaggia classica vado carico
sport tutti
e va bene ma esattamente cosa che mi
ferma se vado a questa velocità niente
varello qualsiasi cosa vai vai così
comunque la soddisfazione vuoi mettere
la soddisfazione di quando lanci tutti
per aria quando veloce non avete idea si
vola ok perfetto è niente si si vola ma
ecco lui non è martin garics prof
ma tu devi per forza a correre su
qualsiasi oggetto che vedi
ecco anche dentro che ho fatto
ok non ho domande ho preso una s
ma direi raga che va bene così per
adesso spero che vide vi sia piaciuto in
realtà quello che volevo dirvi è che se
per caso qualcuno di voi riesce a
battere il record mondiale che ho visto
prima ditemelo mi sentirò molto più
scarso di come non mi senta già adesso
io vi saluto ufficialmente da da sonic
prossimo cosplay so già cosa fare però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cose si
capisce il momento è un mi piace anche
ai social convinto descrizione per
salutarvi sennò è un casino però mi
porta microfono perché sono professional
iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]